[Music]
we're going back to objects that we do
in very strong background checks very
strong emphasis on the mental health of
somebody and we are going to do plenty
of other things going on too long too
many instances this solution is not
going to be a singular thing it's going
to be multifaceted and it's gonna be
created by a collection of different
people working together and people are
dying and we have to stop this we have
to subject if he's not old enough to buy
a drink continue to go and buy a beer
you should not be able to buy a gun at
18 years old fix it should have been one
school shooting and we should have fixed
it and I'm pissed because my daughter
I'm not gonna see again president
holding a very emotional listening
session at the White House earlier today
on the issue of school safety mass
shootings joining us now with reaction
Fox News contributor Tommy Lehren is
with us Turning Point USA found a
Charlie Kirk to me the solution is
simple is that every school should have
a full threat assessment security
assessment retired armed military
retired armed police need to be in the
schools to be a front line of defense
and many said that tonight well I think
that that's the logical solution but at
any time of tragedy it's still with
emotion as it should be I think we
should all be very honest with ourselves
this is a tragic time and we need to let
the victims grieve you know that the
families grieve you need to let them
speak I think everybody here because
we're First Amendment advocates believe
that everybody on either side of the
issue has the right to speak about these
issues and we can come to some kind of a
consensus but I do think that we also
need to tackle the cultural problems at
play it's not just a gun problem and we
should be able to have that conversation
there's got to be full put if we decide
to Charlie that we wanted every single
school in America safe we could do that
we were capable of doing big things you
bring a great point about the threat
assessment it's amazing how many of
these schools have not been been
properly analyzed and they don't even
know and what to do in the case of a
horrific shooting but in moments like
these this will really define the nation
character what our founding principles
are we should be deeply troubled by what
happened but we also have to stay
principled to what we as freedom-loving
Americans really believe and this is
really where it's going to take us to
double down and say you know what we do
think we've had mental health checks but
we shouldn't sacrifice our Second
Amendment rights Bailey but there's
common sense like you said these threat
assessments securing these schools we we
heard mr. just then who lost his
daughter and that soundbite he said when
9/11 happened guess what we secured our
airports it should have only taken one
of these not several and I just want to
point out Daryl Scott and sit on the
board of Rachel's challenge I lost his
daughter Rachel and the Columbine
massacre he's been working on solutions
for 20 years and when when Tommy talks
about a cultural change she spot on
there because we've lost this sense of
connection with one another respect for
your fellow student your classmate is
your friend that needs to be implemented
more than the dinner I mean you're right
we sit there and the whole table is this
it's crazy it's an awareness issue
beyond that is whether we're talking
about terrorism we're talking about
school shootings safety in general it's
an awareness issue like you mentioned
people are bared in their phones they're
not paying attention they're taking
pictures they're on Instagram they're
not seeing what's around them and that
leads to you know less safety in our
schools in our airports and our malls on
the streets we it's so easy if we wanted
to do we do it that's right and you
could take the guns away which I don't
think is a good idea and it's a near
impossibility you can't take the evil
away which is what the culture issue is
all about and be very be very careful in
moments like these to give away your
freedoms because when you do you're
never gonna get them back that's work
Kayla you mentioned evil evil we've
taken God out of our schools and you
take God out of this society and you
will see more and more of this happen on
a daily basis
I really do it's great to see three
young people and there's so many that
that will that are coming to CPAC which
opened today and they'll be here for the
vice president tomorrow the president on
Friday you guys are definitely helping
the country in ways you can't even
measure now thank you all for what you
do